all right so what if you owned your own
restaurant and your food was so good the
Food Network wanted to feature you well
that's what's happened to one local
restaurant Madison Kimbrough joins us
live from chickpeas Mediterranean cafe
near Jones and Flamingo maybe you've
eaten there and Madison's going to show
what they're serving up and tell us how
they got to be on the Food Network good
morning Madison
Sherry you really said it like to be
that good in order to get on the Food
Network that's this place here at
chickpeas Mediterranean Cafe now take a
look I'm here with Mary Bell she is an
employee we are actually sitting in
front of dishes made for Guy Fiore when
he was here back in November so Maribel
tell us about these two dishes this is
exactly what was filmed and what people
will see on January 13th coming up on on
Friday when the the show debuts yeah so
actually these are two one of our most
popular dishes here we have for beef
fillet sultani and here we have our
tandoori chicken uh yeah these School
dishes that's what was featured on the
show now and let's talk about the rice
and then also the salad and we have
bread here as well yes so uh here is our
homemade bread that we actually make
right in front of here on our Bakery and
here we have our beef fillet which is
marinated uh and or ground which is a
combination of also ground beef Kebab we
also have basmani rice a salad grilled
tomatoes and saffron rice and here we
have our tandoori chicken with also
basmati rice or salad and grilled tomato
now for someone that wants to come here
and get a dish like this how much are we
talking usually that this would cost ah
here or be fillet sultani will be around
23. okay yes all right and one last
thing that I want to highlight is this
awesome pan that you see up here Guy
Fiore himself Food Network you can see
he signed it it also says it I guess
November 22nd that's when he was here I
was talking to Mary Bell I was wondering
does he do that for all of the
restaurants that he visited and kind of
puts it up there I thought that was very
cool so stay with us for 6 30 as we are
going to check out more food and get
more details on their big episode debut
coming up next Friday sending it back to
you